yesterday White House chief of staff
John Kelly delivered one of the most
emotional and powerful speeches ever in
the White House press room strong
defense of President Trump's call to the
widow of a fallen soldier he lost his
own son to war seven years ago tonight
we have the stunning reaction of the
congresswoman at the center of that
phone call firestorm Frederica Wilson
seems to be enjoying the spotlight you
mean to tell me that I have become so I
have to tell my kids that I'm a rock
star now she also made some serious
charges after general Kelley accused her
of politicizing the deaths of soldiers I
heard his remarks and I heard him say
that I bragged that I secured the money
for the building of the FBI building in
Miramar that's a lie well his point was
I think that and though you're right he
didn't get the facts right on that was
that empty barrels make the most noise
that's a racist term - I'm thinking
about that when I we looked it up in the
dictionary because I had never heard of
an empty battle and I don't like to be
dragged into something like that okay
empty barrel is racist got felt that is
news to me yeah well everything is
racist these days stories like these are
turning people inside out and I hate
that we do them I don't want to do these
stories I said it yesterday no one walks
away from these stories feeling any
better about themselves or about the
people they like or dislike you just
feel bad I mean joy read I don't know
anything about her but I look at these
tweets that she has I this one where she
says this is amazing to me right here
general Kelly grew up in segregated
Boston in an Irish Catholic neighborhood
where women were bullied in black scorn
and rejected so she just labeled Irish
Catholics racist and misogynist and by
connection to that group general Kelly
and this is a person that the media
often asks why doesn't she have her own
show but this is acceptable now you can
just call anybody or smear anybody as
racist and people just run in fear and
the only thing the only it's so sad the
only thing that can save us from these
stories these emotional spasms sadly is
real news we are living in a superficial
ongoing squabble but when there's a
hurricane or a terror attack we suddenly
realize what's good and that's the I
mean what's what's real in life and
that's the sadness other countries wish
they had these problems they wish they
had this time to sit here and talk about
this this with these ridiculous
emotional conflicts it's pathetic
enjoy read was referencing something was
said on MSNBC let's play it and have kin
react to it when John Kelly was going to
school in oak Square in Brighton in the
Boston Irish neighborhood that he grew
up in the schools were segregated by
custom and practice John Kelly never sat
beside a student like Frederico Wilson
in his elementary school it was a
neighborhood in which calling someone
who looked like Frederico Wilson an
empty barrel was the kindest thing that
would have been said about her you know
what wasn't sacred when he was a kid
growing up where he was growing up black
women or black people responsible uh
it's it's so racist and awful and
horrific these kind of comments I take
personal issue with it as an Irish
Puerto Rican double Catholic should sit
there in judgment and make these
statements about someone who has served
our country faithfully has lost his son
and continues to serve this country in
an admirable way what are these people
thinking do they realize how awful this
makes them look and sound and really
shows what's in their core I mean that's
what's so disturbing to me
and CNN fact-checked weather double or
empty barrel was racist one and they
looked at Plato and Shakespeare
Abraham Lincoln used the phrase they
consulted etymology experts as well as
the American dialect Society and they
found no relationship to racism ever
with that phrase I was puzzling myself
so when I walked and I said this did
great I said how did race get in I mean
I I don't like it you know when people
say something that is to my mind without
foundation especially with regard to
race because to me it then cheapens the
whole thing because I think we have
racism in this country but I just wanted
to say so I think this has become like a
scrum now everybody's just kind of
jumping in but I tend to given my the
way I look at the world want to get to
the facts okay and so when he says when
General Kelly says oh she took credit
for the funding for the FBI headquarters
in Miramar Florida I thought well so
maybe that's what he means by empty
barrel is she takes credits for things
that she didn't do then a video comes
out and it's so is that she did not take
credit for it and he was wrong this is
to me reminding of what happened
yesterday when I thought and President
trumpets weed that she had fabricated
everything with regard to this
conversation he said it was a secret
conversation between him and the widow
well then it comes out no general Kelly
says no that President Crump did say you
know you know the soldier knew what he
was buying it when he went when because
he wasn't he enlisted of his own
volition well it turns out Frederica
Wilson was right again so I think to
myself Wow why are people beating up
Frederica Wilson when she in fact has
been right while they're beating up
Frederica Wilson because she's
essentially hanging her hat on this
horrible issue to try to get national
attention and to build up her name as
evidenced by what she said on air that
now she is a rock star and what a
despicable way to become a household
name for this very issue and I think
does anyone else feel like we've hit
rock bottom in society of this entire
week I just has felt so dirty and I
think John Kelly came out there
yesterday and what he said was so
sobering and what you what I think we
saw from him was just a desperation to
get back to a place of society where
there's respect where there's dignity
where anything is sacred and what I find
so sad
that another widow of a fallen soldier
felt so compelled because of this pile
on a president Trump to release a
private conversation that she had with
the president where he told her that her
husband was a hero come to the White
House
anytime she said that at such a low
point she felt like she was just talking
to another human and I just think we've
reached such a sad place in society that
this is now a week long story
and now someone like general Kelly who
served this country so valiantly is now
under attack and being labeled racist it
is all just so disgusting and sodor it
is disgusting you know that's why I say
I think when you make these charges you
better know what you're talking about
cause it has real weight otherwise I
think it disparages people unnecessarily
but I will say that the woman that
you're talking about said that the
president spoke to her in a way that was
comforting but this week we've also
learned what he apparently promised some
guy 25,000 dollars and didn't pay until
this week does the family and don't
forget he's had a situation now with the
woman who you know spread Rica Wilson
the congresswoman where the where his
account really varies from the reality
the mother of the Dead soldier said she
was offended by what the president said
a few a few things one just to make sure
we have all the facts correct President
Obama had to also say the checks in the
mail when he made some promises about
giving money to some fallen people as
well we have a transcript of the remarks
that Miss Wilson gave and she seems to
take a little bit of credit here's what
she says everybody said it was
impossible I went into attack mode I
went to the speaker I presented it I
dashed it over to the Senate and I put
the senators on notice I put it on their
radar but you know what mom what are you
talking about I'm talking about the
speech that you're not talking about run
by General Kelly that's not right the
name is Zelda you're not dying let me
tell you let me tell you why you're not
playing straight event
let me didn't say it on the stage no but
maybe general can't hurt her bragging
about it
and that was referenced at the briefing
today and Sarah Huckabee Sanders had a
response general Kelly said he was
stunned that representative Wilson made
comments at a building dedication
honoring slain FBI agents about her own
actions in Congress including lobbying
former President Obama on legislation as
general Kelly pointed out if you're able
to make a sacred act like honoring
American heroes all about yourself
you're an empty barrel if you don't
understand that reference I'll put it a
little more simply as we say in the
south all hat no cattle then you know
that most of it was her effusive ly
praising these FBI agents and when she
was talking about what she did in
Congress she was not talking about
forget securing a twenty million dollars
she said there was a lot of
grandstanding he was stunned that she
had taken that opportunity to make it
about herself
my goodness Jessie you see what that was
yes she was talking about her ability to
get the building name for two slain FBI
agents not the funding well when you're
reading that you're deceiving the audio
that's deceiving the audience she's
acting like a braggart taking credit you
know what I say the event did not offer
you know what I think I say it's all
unicorn no horn can we all agree that
these stories are like their what
happens is these are bad stories because
whether it's football kneeling or it's
funerals once it's infused with politics
and the next step is racial politics and
we start picking at the scab we can't
stop til another scab eruption that we
pick at that we don't know where this
where where do we want to end up with
identity politics if America is
eternally eating each other alive what
is the solution when it would what does
a social stop to stop and it said we
count incumbent upon the media as well
to say who cares if this is good for
ratings it's bad for the country Wow
that's wrong but don't you think that
Donald Trump plays it I think we're I
think we're all guilty
oh no absolutely but what does she have
to gain by this kind of behavior and you
know just really horrific towards gold
star families racist towards general
Kelly stepping on the backs of gold star
families
I don't like it at all and I'm quite
certain the American people don't like
it it's very much so conduct unbecoming
and general Kelly is a gold star parent
yes now he is under attack
so there you have